corona risiko flüchtlingsheim in den
engen sammelunterkünften häufen sich die
ansteckungen das zeigt eine studie
unruhen nach tod eines schwarzen die
proteste gegen polizeigewalt in den usa
weiten sich aus und werden immer
heftiger und der freizeitspaß kehrt
zurück rechtzeitig zum pfingstwochenende
öffnen weitere vergnügungsparks und auf
an der küste wird ist wieder voller
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag vor pfingsten schön dass
sie dabei sind täglich wachsen die
erkenntnisse über das corona virus
mittlerweile geht die wissenschaft davon
aus dass der großteil der infektionen in
hotspots stattfindet wo einer ganz viele
ansteckt bei gottesdiensten zum beispiel
bei festen oder in schlachthöfen
besonders hoch ist nach einer neuen
studie auch die ansteckungsgefahr im
sammelunterkünften für flüchtlinge eine
herzlich hat details seit wochen steht
die flüchtlingsunterkunft im
brandenburgischen hennigsdorf unter
quarantäne
der grund 84 corona fälle viele der
bewohner leben in mehrbettzimmern sowie
auch barthelemy n d diese zimmer ist 15
quadratmeter und wie diese gründet sie
machen mal gar nicht abstellen machen
15 menschen die sich küche und bad
teilen abstand halten auch hier
unmöglich
in den meisten sammelunterkünften gibt
es eine hohe personen dichte sind viele
menschen auf engem raum gibt
mehrbettzimmer duschen und
sanitäranlagen küchen werden gemeinsam
genutzt
darüber hinaus gibt es eine dynamische
population das heißt die belegung
wechselt und zuständig für menschen zu
forscher der universität bielefeld haben
in 42 flüchtlingsunterkünften in
deutschland corona fälle registriert
hennigsdorf ist nur ein beispiel von
vielen besonders hoch sind die zahlen in
bremen mit circa 200 infizierten in
ellwangen mit 406 und im bayerischen
geldersheim mit 137 auch bartholemy nd
infizierte sich mit dem corona virus
ging nichts an und seiner arbeit als
altenpflegehelfer in einem seniorenheim
nach ein szenario auf das viele seit
beginn der pandemie hinwiesen auch
deshalb müsse sich die wohnsituation der
flüchtlinge dringend ändern
ich setze mich immer dafür ein dass wir
mehr in richtung unterkünfte und
unterbringung in wohnungen und
wohnverbundes gehen
ich denke das ist ein ziel ob der
landesregierung aber das wird
innerhalb von drei wochen gerade wenn
wir in einer corona pandemie stecken zu
erreichen sein bartolomeo nd ist wieder
gesund und hatte glück seine chefin bot
ihm ein zimmer in der
senioreneinrichtung an die zeit in der
flüchtlingsunterkunft hat für ihn ein
ende
die kollegen von frontal21 bleiben an
dem thema dran und berichten ausführlich
am dienstag darüber und wir bleiben beim
thema ansteckungsgefahr
erneut hat es in einer kirchengemeinde
viele chor ohne infektionen gegeben
in bremerhaven wurden in einer
evangelischen pfingstgemeinde 44
menschen positiv auf das virus getestet
fast 150 mussten in quarantäne
man stehe noch am anfang den der kontakt
ermittlungen so die behörden
vor etwa drei wochen kam es bereits in
frankfurt am main zu einer massen
infektion nach einem gottesdienst
endlich wieder jeden tag schule davon
träumen eltern und mittlerweile sicher
auch einige schüler denn die schulen
sind zwar wieder offen doch von
normalbetrieb kann überhaupt keine rede
sein
unter anderem auch weil lehrer fehlen
viele haben sich krank gemeldet weil sie
fürchten sich anzustecken und zu
risikogruppen gehören
elisabeth schmidt der schultag der 3d in
hannover-linden beginnt mit händewaschen
abstand halten einzelne tische wenn
gruppenarbeit dann mit plexiglas
trennwand ich fühle mich sicher durch
diese ganzen regeln die wir haben
dadurch dass die kinder wirklich sich
auch an die regeln halten
doch es gibt auch lehrkräfte die zur
risikogruppe zählen zwölf prozent im
bundesschnitt
aber auch jüngere pädagogen lassen sich
krankschreiben sie alle fallen für den
unterricht im schulgebäude aus nach
einer zdf umfrage ist das zurzeit rund
ein drittel in mecklenburg vorpommern
und nordrhein westfalen etwa ein fünftel
in ländern wie niedersachsen in anderen
regionen um die zehn prozent
hier weiß markierte länder konnten keine
genauen angaben machen
es gibt sicherlich immer schwarze schafe
auch bei den lehrern wenn sie zur
risikogruppe gehören dann können die
natürlich keinen präsenzunterricht
machen ich denke da muss wirklich
verpflichtend von den bundesländern von
den kultusministerien kommen dass hier
im fernunterricht weiterbildung
stattfinden
problem in geschlossenen räumen durch
niesen sprechen atmen fliegen tröpfchen
durch die luft schwerere sinken zu boden
aber die leichteren micro tröpfchen aero
sole genannt schweben bis zu mehreren
stunden lang in der luft und können wohl
eine ansteckung über die atemwege
belasten
es gibt eine studie die zeigt dass skoda
virus zwei sich in diesem jahr sollen
mehr als drei stunden aufhalten kann und
tatsächlich auch noch infektiös ist also
muss das ziel sein räume gut zu
durchlüften damit die ihre sohle bildung
verhindert wird oder ausgedünnt wird
fenster auf das geht allerdings nicht in
allen schulgebäuden und in allen etagen
trotzdem ist homeschooling auf dauer
wohl keine lösung
ich bin das so eigentlich ganz gut und
wir haben wenn wir uns helfen müssen uns
nicht zu nahe kommen grundschüler in
schleswig-holstein sollen bereits in
einer guten woche wieder im
klassenverband unterrichtet werden
weitere länder wollen folgen das wird
nicht gehen ohne dass wir eine
atemschutzmaske pflicht auch in den
klassenzimmern haben wir werden
wahrscheinlich dann auch infektionen nur
dann zurückverfolgen können wenn wir
reihen testungen machen lehrkräfte und
schüler auf abstand unterricht bleibt
eine herausforderung die aktuelle
entwicklung in deutschland zeigt die
zahl der neuinfektionen ist leicht
gestiegen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage steckten sich
täglich 450 menschen an
insgesamt registrierte die johns hopkins
universität stand 18 30 mehr als 182.000
infizierte davon gelten mehr als 100
64.000 als genesen 8497 menschen sind in
verbindung mit profit 19 gestorben
und jetzt ist matthias fornoff bei mir
weil er den guten namen mit dem neuen
politbarometer und das zeigt verblüffen
dass in sachen kuranyi ja zum beispiel
dass sich die deutschen mittlerweile
viel mehr sorgen um die wirtschaft
machen als
um die gesundheit fast drei viertel
erwarten dass sich die wirtschaftslage
in deutschland stark verschlechtern wird
28 prozent glauben das nicht
interessanterweise aber rechnen die
allermeisten nämlich 86 prozent nicht
damit dass ihre eigene finanzielle lage
sich stark verschlechtert wie denken die
befragten über die angedachten
wirtschaft helfen
dann nehmen wir zum beispiel die
kaufprämien für autos heißt diskutiert
aber die werden eher skeptisch gesehen
nur neun prozent sind ohne wenn und aber
dafür 28 prozent wollen hilfen nur für
umweltfreundliche autos und die mehrheit
von 61 prozent ist komplett gegen die
kaufprämie und finanzhilfen für
besonders betroffene länder in der eu
finden im prinzip 61 prozent richtig
aber eine mehrheit von 56 prozent mit
krediten helfen 37 prozent finden auch
zusätzliche hilfen die nicht
zurückgezahlt werden müssen in ordnung
interessant ist ja auch das von den
regierungsparteien immer noch die union
punkten kann aber die spd überhaupt
nicht das ist seit vielen wochen so und
es bestätigt sich auch heute wenn am
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
bliebe die union mit abstand stärkste
kraft 39 prozent plus 1 im vergleich zur
umfrage vor zwei wochen
der koalitionspartner spd stagniert bei
15 prozent
afg 9 -1 fdp 4 - 1 erstmals seit mehr
als vier jahren unter der fünf prozent
hürde
linke 8 und grüne 19 prozent plus eins
wurde reiche beute ich noch sagen für
schwarz grün aber auch für schwarz rot
wäre das nur bedingt muss gesagt werden
vielen dank
alle ergebnisse des politbarometers gibt
es später im heute-journal und jederzeit
in der zdf- heute in die usa wo zwei
themen die menschen auch fühlen zum
einen eskaliert der streit zwischen
präsident jump und twitter was auch mit
dem anderen brennpunkt zu tun hat den
sich ausweitenden und immer heftigeren
protesten nach dem tod eines schwarzen
in minneapolis das ende einer festnahme
am montag ein polizist gibt minutenlang
auf dem hals von george wright obwohl
der immer wieder fleht ich kann nicht
atmen
über die vergangene protest nacht und
die reaktion des präsidenten ines trams
minneapolis am frühen morgen
hundertschaften der polizei und soldaten
der nationalgarde marschieren auf und
versuchen ruhe in ein aufgewühltes
brennendes viertel zu bringen in der
nacht zuvor war das regelrecht verloren
gegeben worden
demonstranten lassen ihrer wut freien
lauf george floyd rufen sie den namen
des afroamerikaners der am montag hier
verstand die polizeistation der vier
beamten die an der festnahme beteiligt
waren wird in brand gesetzt
einige der demonstranten plündern leben
und supermärkte die behandlung von
schwarzen in amerika ist irrwitzig ganz
und gar nicht okay es ist sehr traurig
und das geht nun schon seit vielen
jahren so es ist zeit das zu ändern denn
wir sind dessen solide
in der nacht befeuert präsident tramper
twitter die aufgeheizte stimmung er
spricht von gangstern und warnt wenn die
plünderungen beginnen beginnt das
schießen twitter markiert diesen tweet
als gewaltverherrlichend ein warnhinweis
der sicherlich trans wut auf die
sozialen medien weiter schüren wird dem
bürgermeister von minneapolis wirft er
mangelnde führung vor greift der nicht
durch so trump werde ich soldaten
schicken und den job richtig erledigen
donald trump weiß nichts über die stärke
von minneapolis wir sind fälle stark ist
dies eine schwierige zeit ja aber ihr
könnt verdammt sicher sein wir werden
das schaffen können
die festnahme von george floyd am montag
neun minuten hatte er das knie des
polizisten am hals er erstickt die
polizisten sind entlassen aber nicht
angeklagt ein ganzes stadtviertel von
minneapolis ein schlachtfeld jede stunde
die eine anklage auf sich warten lässt
könnte weitere proteste hervorrufen
schon bevor twitter trumps minneapolis
tweet als gewaltverherrlichend
gekennzeichnet hat hatte der
us-präsident dem kurznachrichtendienst
den kampf angesagt trump unterzeichnete
einen erlass mit dem sozialen netzwerke
künftig stärker reglementiert werden
sollen vor drei tagen hatte twitter
einen trump tweet zur briefwahl mit
einem faktencheck versehen maly ist ein
extrem gefährliches land jederzeit ist
mit anschlägen der islamisten mit
überfällen und entführungen zu rechnen
die bundeswehr ist dort seit sieben
jahren im einsatz heute hat der
bundestag diesen um ein jahr verlängert
und ausgeweitet künftig sollen mehr
soldaten in dem westafrikanischen land
eingesetzt werden ihre eigentliche
mission ausbilden und stabilisieren
doch das wird gerade auch in corona
zeiten immer riskanter tim krüger
berichtet die sicherheitslage in der
region wird immer kritischer terror
gewalt vertreibung deswegen sollen
zukünftig bis zu 100 weitere bundeswehr
soldaten in die region geschickt werden
können
die eu ausbildungsmission soll neben
manny auf andere kritische sahel staaten
ausgeweitet werden die deutschen
soldaten sollen die lokalen kräfte näher
an den einsätzen aus bilden die
zentralen mali ist ein trainingszentrum
geplant derzeit sind die lehrgänge wegen
der korona pandemie ausgesetzt die
patrouillen der deutschen un soldaten in
nord mali wurden nicht reduziert aber
die persönlichen gespräche finden nur
noch in ausnahmefällen stadt verlassen
beziehungsweise wieder ist gerade
einfach über verteilt ist
funktionsmittel und begrenzen unseren
kontakte mit der bevölkerung auch das
zwingt notwendige maß terror religiöse
konflikte kriminalität und nun auch noch
corona mehrfacher krisenmodus
profitieren könnten die islamistischen
gruppierungen im sahel zurück nach
deutschland corona verändert vieles auch
unsere essgewohnheiten so wird deutlich
mehr gekocht das zeigt der neue
ernährungs report der bundesregierung
1.000 verbraucher wurden befragt
landwirtschaftsministerin klöckner
präsentierte heute die ergebnisse
regionales wird beliebter
vor allem bei frischem obst und gemüse
sowie bei milchprodukten und eiern
ein weiterer trend weniger fleisch
stephanie rein auf den berliner kollwitz
markt kommen viele händler mit ihren
produkten aus der region und regionale
lebensmittel das sagt der neue
ernährungs report seien inzwischen für
vier von fünf befragten wichtig für
viele habe die landwirtschaft in der
korona krise an bedeutung gewonnen
michael gassmann ist regelmäßig mit
ihrem stand hier zu ihr kommen längst
nicht nur die stammkunden
stadt-anzeiger maschine die er
wahrscheinlich durch das fastenessen gar
nicht bis jetzt dazugekommen sind sich
mit essen auseinanderzusetzen oder wo
dann mal auf die frage kam
wissen sie wie das meine mutti gemacht
hat 30 prozent der menschen kochen
derzeit häufiger als vor den corona
beschränkungen so die studie
bei käse brot gemüse wird auf die
herkunft geachtet auch die hühnchen aus
dem spreewald sind immer recht schnell
weg doch beim fleischkonsum insgesamt
gibt es veränderungen berichtet die
landwirtschaftsministerin während 2015
noch 34 prozent der befragten angaben
täglich wurst und fleisch zu essen
kommen laut der aktuellen befragung nur
noch bei 26 prozent jeden tag fleisch
waren auf den teller
die zahl derer die gelegentlich bewusst
auf fleisch verzichten hat zugenommen
über die hälfte der befragten 55 prozent
bezeichnen sich als flexitarier rein
vegetarisch oder vegan leben nur sechs
prozent der befragten
am wichtigsten für alle ist dass das
essen schmeckt dazu solle es gesund sein
und sich schnell zubereiten lassen
außerdem das sagt die studie auch noch
schauen die käufer auf die kalorien und
den preis appetit haben viele menschen
auf noch etwas auf normalität nach und
nach enden viele corona beschränkungen
schwimmbäder dürfen wieder öffnen
und nun auch einige freizeitparks
pünktlich zum langen pfingstwochenende
allerdings gelten auch hier masken
pflicht und abstandsregeln simon von z
es sind nur ein paar momente aber sie
sind ganz weit weg vom corona alltag der
fall in die tiefe ein bisschen ablenkung
danach suchen viele heute im europa park
gleich am ersten tag war mal ab stunde
in der warteschleife
denn tickets gab es nur vorab im
internet 10.000 besucher pro tag das ist
die grenze in normalen zeiten kommen
manchmal fünfmal so viele
die achterbahnen nur halb besetzt es
gilt mundschutz pflicht per app können
die gäste sich selbst kontrollieren
der abstand passt da sind wir
marktführer und für die ganze branche
dass wir mit distanzmessung spielerisch
den gästen sagen können was gut und was
weniger gut ein bisschen richtung
normalität das soll gelingen an diesem
pfingstwochenende auch ganz im norden da
stehen auf dem campingplatz von volker
behrens weniger wohnmobile als sonst
aber immerhin
ich habe mich eigentlich wo finanzielle
und planerische stoffe eingestellt
gehabt dass er frühestens mitte mit juni
wieder loslegen können
also von daher ist das schon gerade das
halbvolle glas das halbleere glas 60
prozent auslastung sind hier
niedersachsen erlaubt das ehepaar
berstermann hat einen platz bekommen sie
blicken vorsichtig optimistisch richtung
fixed feiertage wir werden unsere
radtouren machen
wir werden sicherlich von euch nicht so
viel essen gehen die person zu machen
erst mal war ich sehr skeptisch wegen
seiner der anlagen das gebe ich zu aber
wie gesagt das ganz entspannt eigentlich
ne und es verläuft sich ja auch bei den
wenigen leuten die jetzt hier sehen
ein paar kilometer entfernt da ist die
fähre richtung norderney gut gefüllt für
manche ist dieser urlaub auch eine
kleine flucht wenn man hört dass durch
diese tröpfchen infektion auch durch das
verbreiten keinen geschlossenen räumen
so fühle ich mich wahrscheinlich von der
insel sicherer wenn ich draußen bin viel
einerseits freut man sich dass man außer
garten und arbeite im moment etwas
anderes sieht aber ich sag mal
da war es natürlich auch irgendwie ein
bisschen mit dann legt die fähre ab der
staat in einem pfingstwochenende das
anders sein wird als in den vergangenen
jahren
warum mit viel sonne so war dieser
frühling wir haben es alle erlebt jetzt
haben wir es auch amtlich die vorläufige
bilanz des deutschen wetterdienstes
zeigt es war einer der sonnigsten seit
beginn der aufzeichnungen
gleichzeitig war es aber viel zu trocken
mit etwa 108 liter niederschlag pro
quadratmeter fielen nur gut die hälfte
des durchschnitts der letzten jahre
vor allem im osten fehlt der regen was
macht ein radprofi ohne wettkämpfe
er findet selbst eine herausforderung
für emanuel buchmann vierter bei der
tour de france ist es der mount everest
nur eben nicht direkt der höchste berg
der welt sondern die alpen im ötztal
immer denselben berg hoch und runter bis
die 8848 höhenmeter des motors erreicht
sind rund neun stunden lang zugunsten
eines guten zwecks
das wetter wird ab pfingstmontag richtig
schön zuvor gibt es hier und da noch ein
bisschen regen die details hat gleich
katja vorne fahren das heute journal um
22 uhr mit claus kleber
hier übernimmt morgen petra gerster
ihnen danke ich sehr hat sich für ihr
interesse wünsche ihnen ein schönes
pfingstwochenende alles gute und sagt
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das ist
eine recht eingefahrenen wetterlage über
westeuropa dominiert der sonnenschein
über osteuropa dominieren die wolken das
bleibt auch jetzt in der nacht so da
kann es nämlich durchaus einige
wolkenfelder hier in ostdeutschland
geben im westen dagegen ist es häufig
klar bei nordostwind und so sinken die
temperaturen auf 11 bis 3 grad und am
alpenrand reicht es also noch mal für
bodenfrost morgen klettern die werte in
der westhälfte auf 19 bis 25 grad im
osten bleibt es deutlich frischer
nur so 14 bis 18 grad das liegt daran
dass dort etwas dichtere wolken
unterwegs sind aber selbst in sachsen
und in bayern sind regenschauer doch so
gut wie ausgeschlossen
sehr viel sonniger ist es dagegen in der
westhälfte von der nordseeküste bis zum
bodensee strahlt die sonne und am
pfingstsonntag da warten wir wohl bis in
den späten nachmittag bis dann die
regenwolken in niederbayern an kommen
sonst wird das ein freundlicher tag bei
14 bis 23 grad und ab pfingstmontag
stehen dann die zeichen auf die sommer
es wird von tag zu tag sonniger und
wärmer am mittwoch erwarten uns 21 bis
30 grad
schöner